how would it check if a property isn't
an object here we have an object just my
object named Jace nuggets that's the
property and a lot of people to check if
the property is an object do this so you
can say it's gonna say it is in here but
there are actually two native ways for
checking if an object is in that
property that sometimes are better than
just saying if I picked out my name
there so let me show you those there's
the in operator and there's the has own
property
function so here's an example of those
now if we run both these we can see true
and true my object that has on property
names gonna be true and named in my
object so those are the two ways heads
on property and in however there's
something to keep in mind with these has
own property will only return true if
the key is available on that object
directly however in will show true
whether it's created directly on the
object or if the property is inherited
from the prototype chain let me show you
an example of that it's going to pay
these but I'm gonna put in a different
property here so value of is a property
on all objects however it's not one that
we specifically created on this object
value of is just part of the prototype
of an object so let's run that and see
what happens
so you'll see at the end false true
so has on property value of is showing
false the value of in my object is
showing true so those are just a few
ways to check if a properties of in an
object thanks for watching my name is
beau Carnes don't forget to subscribe
and remember use your code for good